siamo pronti a fare altre figure di
questo gioco è la risposta è sì bella
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovissimi episodi di scramble punto io
come sempre entro nelle partite c'è già
un famigerato del demonio non è
possibile però vabbè la gente si fini si
si si finge me fa niente vediamo che il
migliore dal punteggio amico mio clicca
e un coniglio con un orecchino la vj
finto sulle famiglie ad essere me allora
poi la dovete smettere
manco dovessi farvi vedere la carta di
identità
il vincitore sarà il vero
la risposta era sandali mia nonna li
avrebbe fatti molto meglio in tutto
questo io ho inveito contro gli altri
allora messo l'aggiornamento
parrucchiere aggiornamento parrucchiere
vai let's golf
proviamo dai ragazzi ma che bravo ma che
bravo fire ghiere madonna faticare per
non averlo indovinato prova ok non si
capisce niente golf cart
ma cos'è un golf cart noi that ideale
sembra una mazza da golf all'inizio e
questa prova vaiana sorprendi si fragola
no però a polmoni polmoni cuore polmoni
no a polmone 1a perché aveva già chi tra
polmoni izik solo che questa altro non
saprà leggere l'inglese quindi ho vinto
io ho vinto io perché non siete capaci
lui poi genera altro è uscito perché
faceva cagare ha capito che poteva
poteva fare a meno di competere col vero
quindi va bene grazie ragazzi grazie al
polmone ho vinto io grazie meglio di
anna e di paco industria detenzione
aspirapolvere punto scommetti subito
europeo
pensa se per caso ma c'è il paradiso
avrei toccato a materasso chi è ha poi
dominato per c'entra niente prestito
aspira moto sopra perché iscritto una
roba che non c'entrava niente
sotto acidi ok il vomito maledizione
sono fortissimo grazie pianola tricolore
ghirla d'irlanda
yeah italia mid cap rom italia vedi che
arancione aran arancione mine minestrone
ragazzi era facile non disegnare la
ganja porco demonio è bravo a
cancellarne si è preso malissimo irlanda
dai l'hai fatta bene la gente che
demente hai fatto benissimo con chi sto
giocando con topo gigio sono primo sito
round ho vinto io no
fiammifero accendino cioè io ho
indovinato accendino da un quadrato nero
raga porco demonio tutto qua
tutto qua indovinato che si parlano
indovineranno neanche anche l'anno in
meno adesso bravo hai fatto anche bene
una fiamma ti stimo però tovagliolo
palla di fuoco perfetto allora io sono
pronto a fare una palla di fuoco ma non
so con quale criterio sempre utilizzando
il tuo schema di colori
ok tac tac non ha sbagliato
l'arancione soldi e rosso ok e adesso ce
n'è uno bravo perché ho indovinato e
adesso cede 1 e questo è una palla di
fuoco dai era facile porco demonio era
una palla di fuoco o potevo fare il mago
che la lancia vada era difficilissima
disegnare esterno che doma stride no
tangenziale autostrada vede che c'è
minuti mette a tutti corrono gi oh oh oh
oh oh no non ci sarà presa cacchio è sta
roba no ragazzi veramente marco lami non
lo faceva meglio fuga di gas che ha
disegnato laboratorio ma cosa mi
rappresenta
vai anna forza diciamo tutti per te
questo è un'altra tac un cane
no è un
inquinamento io veramente non ne yo yo
yo yo veramente ma se vedi che non sei
in grado di disegnare inquinamento non
scegliere inquinamento c'erano 300 modi
per disegnarlo meglio ce n'erano e
guarda celano un miliardo di monito e
scelto l'unico per non rappresentarlo ma
se non lo stop nota musicale che pirla
mi sembra un segue il porco demonio
questo l'ho sbagliata acqua vicino
123456 che non sto capendo niente 321 a
distributore ma io voglio capi ma dove
minchia line e disturbi distributore che
distribuisce il vino aspetta che mette
un euro mia scelta bernello no vabbè
ragazzi bellissima e adesso poi io
adesso voglio mi chiede se esco se non
trovo un distributore di tavernello io
me ne vado voglio il distributore di
tavernello ora bellissimo cioè dai porca
vacca bellissimo meritavi la vita
bellissimo
non c'era il coso per mettere i soldi
non c'erano le cose da prendere non
c'era la maniglia per prenderlo ma c'era
il vino bellissimo ragazzi questa
meravigliosa comunque a pisa a lato a
torre di pisa
ma non è di quel colore ma davvero sei
sicuro sicurissimo
perché secondo me era di quel colore di
fit e sbagliando sembra più un tronchi
sembra più una la verità la cacca di
marco merlino è fatta così dei arancia
loculo mandarino che cacchio è zucca di
halloween
proprio lui bravo fratello questa
veramente difficile ragazzi cosa vuoi
che sia
madonna che competizione a 0 che siamo
cioè dai da un cuoco non un prete veloso
adesso scrivono tutti cuoco tac e poi la
croce di gesù era mettiamo oa
ok ma non è vestitosi o e fallo tu c'hai
ma che non ho capito io non pretendere
facco e rotti gliela scritto lui inizia
la croce devi farla prima è fatto lo to
manaccia miseria e già già tanto che
sono per una volta ho preso un 6 in arte
pure pretendono pure terremoto canyon
grand canyon e una bolletta e un fusillo
fusillo brutto per cancelliamo io
rimango estasiato ogni volta da un
piccone e litio
l'ho riconosciuto solo perché del dfi
piccoli diamante di minecraft bellissimo
ma dove è bene perché ma perché solo
perché di diamante ragazzi l'ultima è
questa
vi viva la viva la fip
[Musica]